President Trump will welcome French
president de men WOM at Kron to the US
today they plan to discuss the Iran
nuclear agreement which mr. Trump is
thinking of scrapping McCraw who
supports the Iran deal said yesterday
that the US needs allies and France can
be one major Garrett is at the White
House where officials are also working
on a potential summit with North Korea
major good morning good morning in that
context the White House knows North
Korea will tempted with small
concessions in hopes of winning big
economic benefits from America that is
after all the North Korean playbook and
it has worked in the past so the big
question here this weekend how big were
Pyongyang's nuclear concessions well the
answer here and from top Republicans in
Congress not nearly big enough
president Trump sounded hopeful after
leaving from a week at mar-a-lago that
followed an overly optimistic tweet
suggesting North Korea quote agreed to
denuclearization the North has done no
such thing but that is the White House
goal Pyongyang did agree to close its
nuclear test site and suspend long-range
ballistic missile tests as both sides
negotiate a potential summit in May or
June it's an easily reversible decision
and they made no announcement about
their medium or short-range ballistic
missiles Republicans said they are
skeptical North Korea is ready to
abandon nuclear weapons this is a great
public relations effort by Kim jong-un
summit preparations coincide with am a
deadline to renew the 2015 Iran nuclear
deal that president Trump has threatened
to abandon a move that could allow Iran
to restart its pursuit of nuclear
weapons I do think he will move away
from the agreement on May 12 if that
happens in Foreign Minister Mohammad
Javad Zarif said on Face the Nation that
Iran is ready to resume its nuclear
program if the benefits of the deal for
Iran start to diminish then there is no
reason for Iran to remain in the deal
French president Emmanuel macron said
the agreement while flawed has real
security advantages it's for nuclear
what do you have at the better option I
don't see it
McCrone who is said to meet with the
president this week could sway mr.
Trump's Iran decision both of us are
probably the Maverick of the systems
France Germany and Great Britain all
want the United States to stay in the
Iran nuclear deal that means changing
president Trump's mind and to do that
the three countries are looking to add
side agreements to make the deal tougher
on Iran after a president micron leaves
German Chancellor Angela Merkel comes to
the White House for a working visit
later this week the part of the Germany
France tag team to change the
president's mind and preserve if
possible the Iran nuclear deal meanwhile
it was a crazy busy week for the
president on Twitter weekend rather for
the President on Twitter a record number
of tweets this weekend for this calendar
year gale but we must acknowledge it's
only April
many months ago he had a lot to say this
weekend thank you very much major